here to respond former counselor to
president trump kellyanne conway
all right kellyanne so don't worry about
the shootings
the assaults
pushing people into subway tracks worry
about me i'm the dangerous extremist i
think you're great for their ratings i
think they are great for moderation
arrangement syndrome by the way
congratulations on waters universe thank
you very much we're expanding look this
is a very serious time when we were in
the trump white house we always heard
the word chaos chaos chaos in his tweets
chaos and an off-handed remark here now
there is chaos which means uncertainty
insecurity turmoil everywhere you look
chaos at the southern border chaos of
the gas pump chaos in the grocery store
chaos in ukraine chaos with rising
prices chaos in our schools chaos and
workplaces are we going back can we go
back
and people feel that insecurity that
uncertainty now and more than that
they're blaming joe biden
close to 70 don't want him to run again
it's not just joe biden either it's his
vice president who's unpopular and the
democratic party so those who are lining
up and salivating that we'll just get
rid of incapacitated joe don't realize
they'll still have the incompetent
democratic party and they're part of it
these fools went into his cabinet they
voted for his terrible legislation on
capitol hill so they're like joe biden
jesse they're going to own and eat all
of his policies crime
it's just like 1994 all over again i
worked on the contract with america as a
batch backbencher with frank luntz with
newt gingrich with uh haley barber and
that contract with america by the time
we were polling the public and polling
candidates and office holders and other
opinion leaders crime was up there with
the economy as a top issue go back and
look at the polls in the summer of 1994.
i'm seeing that all over again but it
means that security and affordability
are the two themes going into these
midterms and on both joe biden scores
very poorly and the cable networks are
denying crimes a problem i i don't see
how that's going to solve their
credibility crisis uh and that's just
idiocy
uh something happened today i'm a little
bit jealous because it didn't happen to
me
um we'll set it up this way remember
what joe biden said on his first day in
office roll it
but i'm not joking when i say this
if you're ever working with me and i
hear you treat another colleague with
disrespect
talk down to someone i promise you i
will fire you on the spot
on the spot
well joe might not realize it but
he's fired listen
will you take questions on inflation
then let's move on thank you thank you
thank you you think in places of
political liability ahead of the
midterms
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid sound [ __ ]
now ducey is a stupid sob but i'm the
only one who's allowed to say that the
president can't say that they're working
overtime tonight on social media i'm
sure with the what about is him and
trump etc uh and this is the second time
in a week that a fox news white house
correspondent has been derided and
castigated by the president united
states and jackie heinrich jackie
heinrich i i hate twitter but i had
tweeted out that uh jackie was accused
of asking a quote stupid question it was
an excellent and timely question about
sanctions against russia and there
president biden called her question
stupid here he called the actual
reporter stupid but this is a guy who in
that same nbc news poll jesse is seen as
no longer easygoing and likable so his
personal attributes have created along
with job approval of these of these
major issues and this is a guy remember
he said he'd like to take donald trump
out behind the high school gymnasium and
punch him in the nose so um this is a
guy with a terrible temper he's not
taking happy pills on the weekends in
wilmington clearly but a serious point
on the crime thing very quickly george
gasco in l.a larry krasner in
philadelphia alvin bragg here in
manhattan these are guys they are
forcing our law enforcement to retire
early to resign they're not arresting
they're doing no cash bail they enhance
sentencing aren't happening in la
the the train um people united pacific
ask for help with the supply chain
crisis they're letting criminals ransack
and then have a second chance to do it
again the same week this is serious they
want you to not believe there are
homicides we either have dead bodies or
we don't we had 12 cities breaking
homicide records last year on joe
biden's watch it's a real thing if biden
would get as angry as he did with peter
ducey about crime in this country
i think people would respect that a lot
more but it's a democratic problem not
just a joke
good luck thank you killian has no
problems
trust me hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else